你说我现在拿的终身成就奖
我今年4月拿的荣誉博士
这个是大家给我的荣耀
我都非常地珍惜
我可以保证我做到的就是做最好的自己
我演的是自己
我演自己的时候我很害羞
我演别人的时候
人家给我理由去做那个喜怒哀乐
那个情绪的发展
我演自己的我林青霞
我就觉得我就很害羞
我觉得我很是找到了一个港口
我结婚这么多还是这么多
记者还没停过
我一点都没有想过拍电影的事
但是我并没有忘了拍电影
我还是很爱表演
很爱电影
嗨大家好
欢迎来到今天的看板人物
待会要为您介绍的
今天这位来宾
他刚刚得到了一份极高的荣誉
而这个荣誉不只是肯定了他个人的终身成就
更重要的我觉得他是肯定了一位职人一生悬命
一生专注
让人带来的尊敬以及敬佩
他个人就可以创造境界和高度
让我们一起来欢迎金马奖
第60届终身成就奖得主林青霞小姐
青霞姐很高兴见华
欢迎你来
欢迎欢迎青霞姐
这一次来台湾的时间是旋风式的
短短的时间她是非常高兴
青霞姐很久没进电视台了
对不对啊
不知道几十年了都忘了好
那就让我们这一次空前跟绝后
别人不用想也不用想
就记得看板人物就对了
欢迎青霞姐
让我们就做新版人物
谢谢青霞姐好
我们开始来聊聊请坐
相信青霞姐这一次来台湾领到金马奖
第60届的终身成就奖
一定有太多人啊
在您坐下来接受我访问的是
之前已经问过您有什么样的感想
有什么样的心情哈
所以我的开场还是非常想问一下
你面对台下做了这么多引人这么多追梦的人哦
你想那时候您谈的时候
你分享的最主要的价值和信念是什么
一个人可以一生悬命追梦呢是绝对可以达到的
因为你说我现在拿的终身成就奖
我今年4月拿的荣誉博士
对我这个梦都不敢追
我根本不敢做这个梦
我拿到了
变成我的
可以说是我生命的高光时刻
真的真的
所以追梦就尽量去追
一定可以达到
而且呢要抱着锲而不舍的精神
你就进去就好了
你进去呢或许3年两年不成
10年一定成一个人专注在一样
他有兴趣的事情
他会他会真的是他会钻研比别人家更多力气
而且不累不累不困
没想到好像是青霞姐写作的时候
完完全全不累
不困不饿
绝对时间都忘记了
所以写作也是你过去从来梦也没有梦过
没写作也没梦
拍戏也没梦
不是是根本觉得这是不可能的事情
你看这个这一次第60届我们的影后是12岁
我想这也带给很多新的时代
新的经历
这个年轻的时代可以不断地继续的追梦
绝对我觉得2023可能你也没有想过
会是一个这么不一样的一年
4月份你在香港大学有个荣誉博士
然后呢岁末的时候领到金马奖的终身成就
这两个你有没有一定要回答啦
你有没有到底不喜欢换一个
这个是大家给我的荣耀
我都非常的珍惜
我可以保证我做到的就是做最好的自己
昨天比前天好
今天比昨天好
明天我会比今天好
我这个是我可以保证做到的
金马奖的特刊有一篇很特别的文章啊
这篇文章呢是青霞姐二女儿邢爱林献出的
我的妈妈林青霞
里面最让我意外的是艾琳
她写说我中学啊在演戏剧系的时候
我的深信呢非常害羞
因为我遗传妈妈害羞的天性
让我怎么样都演不好
我要演的人物哦
我们今天看到青霞姐
你所有演过的剧
然后所有人都用东方不败来标志青霞节
所以害羞这个字应该很久
很久没有人跟栖霞姐的特质连在一起
我害羞那个程度你都不敢想象
可以让我们想象一下
有一次我们搭公共汽车学校嘛
学校的同学一大堆同学
公共汽车来的都都这学生呢不守规矩
本来应该排队上
全部都挤到那个门里面
那个门就那么小
大家一起挤
其实我排在前面的全部这么一挤
我我也不好意思
这样子扒着挤啊
我就说你看我这一说全部好像挤上
就把我这样抬到那个抬到那个巴子上面
所以你每天上学都都因为害羞在那边奋战
就对了
我上学奋战那个出社会奋战
我奋战的知道我过了第二个人生之后
就说我现在不是现在过了生日九岁吗
九岁我九岁之前我都在害羞状态
真的还假的哇
所以可是你人生必须经过那么多环境的转换
戏剧形态的转换
但是你其实的内在对于这些转换
害羞和害怕不一样
我每次都在挣扎
我每次出来呃
访问我
我其实之前呢不太交朋友
也不太愿意跟生人在一起
那么我每一次要出镜
我内心里都很大的挣扎
所以我们看到演戏里面那完全是你的经验
我演的是自己
我演自己的时候我很害羞
我演别人的时候
这个人家给我理由去做那个喜怒哀乐
那个情绪的发展
我演自己的我林青霞
我就觉得会就很害羞
所以金陵女中的时候的林青霞
是一直被人家抬的好
拱上这个公车pass这张照片啊
在这一次金马奖终身成就奖引言的影片里面
我们终于看到了好多窗外的片段
因为他并没有正式在戏院上演哈
这是一个剧照
这也是是不是琼瑶阿姨
她今年重新整理她的小说系列集
所以他那本书窗外的封面就是这个
可见他太喜欢这张照片
有没有什么故事
你看我的眼睛
你看我的眼睛有没有一种一点
你看我的表情有没有不是很开心
这个镜头拍之前我大哭啊
你知道吗
我大哭
因为你知道吗
我们台湾初中3年
高中3年都要剪的很短的短头发
那个是耳上的
都要在耳朵上面
后面要剃青皮的
我的头发是我的命啊
这个青皮是绝对不能剃的
所以我这个头发特别重要
毕业之后第一件事情不剪头发留长
然后烫起来
我这刚好到这个肩膀这个长度
我演这个窗外是又要回到学生
是初中生
第一天就把我头发给剪掉了
哎呀我知道是应该剪
但是我哭得不得了
就在这种情况情形况哦
所以这个不是那么入戏的
托腮是那个时候那个天天你看我的表情好好好
可见那个哭是哭的撕心裂肺
然后印象非常的深刻
就是这样子
然后take了这个shot对
很有意思吧
很有意思
我们从窗外弹起来呃
我想呃5年级生啊
4年级生甚至6年级生的
前段
我们记得的台湾的文艺爱情片的辉煌时代啊
80年代直到990年代初
提到文艺爱情片
那时候叫三听片
对不对
你呀别嫌我三听片了
我看一个法国片子
人家一听片呢
整个电影就是一个在餐厅里十几20个人聊天
就是看这个我们餐厅已经对得起你们了
很不错
感谢感谢
而且还是在我们戒烟时代哦
很不容易啊
那时候文艺爱情片的代名词
其实就是林青霞三个字
那呃文艺爱情片
我们在也是在这次的引言的介绍片里面
看到信霞解说站着都可以睡着
是啊站着都可以睡着
我本来想要要示范给你看我
我有一次有一次拍戏打灯光打灯光
有面墙在那边打个灯光
我靠那个墙等
等到我突然间哎预备预备
我才突然之间缓过来醒了
原来我刚才睡着了
好可怕
所以那时候你睡着
你也不知道你醒来
你也不晓得醒来才知道我刚才睡着了
所以那个累的情况是因为我看过青霞姐开始呃
投书啊
写完账后
有一次你回到永康街哦
然后我想那个开门的女孩一定很意外
因为青霞姐就是发现以前老家的公寓
在他的年龄就是我差不多住在那边的年龄
所以你敲门
你问他说你可不可以进来看看
就是你你就跟他说
我以前住在这边
可不可以让我进来看看
她有一点犹豫
她说家里只有他一个人
那我后面郝广才陪我一起上去
好感说她她是林青霞
她是林青
他以前坐在这边
然后你记起了也是那个我想说一个人可以多累
你说你累到回家眯一下的时候
你常常妆都没卸
然后是你母亲唐氏唐氏
然后你就躺着
她让你睡
然后她帮你谢是啊
常常是这样
累成这个样子
常常是旁氏帮我谢谢
还没卸完
我就睡着了哇
那家人的真的是一点没改变
几十年都没变
我就直接上去那个大铁门
我妈把我锁在外面的大铁门
我进去了
这个那个阳台没变
鞋柜没变
然后进去房间没变
那个我的房间
我妹妹的房间没变没变没变通通没变
那个那个落地玻璃没变
走过去
我妈房间没
我爸妈妈房间没变
我哥哥房间没变
在我哥哥房间发现一个这么样的一个单张仪
你说你没有勇气
有没有很感动
我是觉得好像恍如隔世啊
然后我就感觉上以前琼瑶平鑫涛在这里跟我谈
拍戏
以前一个制片在这边一讲三四个钟头疲劳轰炸
弄得我没办法
只有答应以前谁谁谁来找我
以前有一个制片说我再不接他就要跳楼啊
很多都浮上心头
就是在我去那边去完之后
我久久地在那边回想
所以在那个客厅里面曾经有多少人
那我简单来讲
其实他们就是直接到永康街
你的老家去抢人就对了
到处抢啊
哪里那么简单呢
我有一次我在阳明山拍戏
应该是旗正飘飘
旗正飘飘拍戏
我记得我穿一件粉红色的晚礼服
跟那个林峰林林峰在在一起演
那他们跟我说有三个字
骗上山来找你
嘎七
除了我们这边一个制片
还有外面三个制片上来
他们都带了武士刀
我啊需不需要武士刀啊
到最后没办法了
怎么谈成了呢
一个人八个小时我就不用睡觉了
我这边八个小时拍完
那个人接那个八个小时
这个人接
你知道吗
我是不想接那么多戏的
台湾人情压力太大
你说人家要跳楼
你能不接吗
你说那个叔叔uncle这么求你哦
你说那个那个认识的人
那你说他都不接刀那么大能不接吗
没有武士刀那么大还还
但枪就很小很多啊
枪怎么少啊
没少过啊
太可没少过
我现在讲可不可以啊
现在那个几十年过去了
应该没问题吧
所以你是独自去面对这些比较复杂的压力
你母亲会母亲没有帮你
有我母亲都我父母对这个行业
其实不要说我们全家跟所有的亲戚朋友
都对这个行业没有任何认识
那么当然有帮了
那时候不流行经纪人
经纪人都是星妈出面
也没有什么都没有
就我一个人谈片酬
看剧本呃
这个呃服装化妆发型都是自己
不是自己拍戏
一空档就出去买衣服
那每一个演员的衣服都是自己的
所以你的品味怎么样
就是就是电影里面就是那样子
所以在这样的生活
它运转了这么久以后
这文艺爱情片的时间很长
呃
你后来会不会对于我们讲两个号
一个是工作
包括了你要处理这么多事
一个是戏剧演戏本身
再一个身心这么过量的情况下
你有没有过觉得嗯有点想
我可不可以不演了
我崩溃了
我在片场片场崩溃了
我那时候最大的感觉就是我的弦要断了啊
我要离开这个圈子
我不要见所有跟这个圈子有关系的人
我不要以你什么什么都不要有关系
因为我想逃离
甚至我想去美国做waitress都好好呀
我想做WARESS
你没有压力吗
对不对
这就没有人认得
没人认得
我在里面还还蛮自在的
但是还好
后来还是有好的骗子把青霞姐抓了回来哦
那后来呢
台湾我们渐渐的进入到了这个80年代
其实在昨天的呃金马奖终身成就奖颁奖
我觉得最感人的段落是呃
介绍青霞姐的啊
李安导演的影片
她也让我们看到青霞姐啊
是整个一个时代的全部的呃
电影工作
华人电影的重量
浓缩在青霞姐一个人所超越的各种挑战上面
80年代的时候
台湾进入他们说新写实电影嘛
青霞姐
您也做了一个新的转变哈
那时候您会选择去香港啊
这个很大很大的转变
香港距离我们还是很遥远
心理距离很遥远
你怎么样做的这个决定
新浪潮兴起的时候
我还在美国等等
我从美国回来呢
呃其实也差不多
那么我回来的时候
我在适应期
就是朱延平找我
朱延平就是很会拍那种喜剧片
叫红名卖座的那种喜剧片
啊啊红粉兵团迷你特工队四傻害羞啊
想起来了
七只狐狸
四傻害羞
还是我取的名字
你取我取的
你怎么知道还没取片名
我就说那就是傻害羞
就是个傻瓜嘛
是四傻
害羞呃
都都很卖座
我因为我很多人找我
很多人找我
那我又要逃了
我这个我又要逃
我就不接任何戏
我就到香港
我觉得香港没有人情压力
但刚好那时候香港很多导演都想找我
一个台湾的演员去香港有个新鲜感
我觉得香港对我觉得最舒服的
就是说他们很实际
你不演
他们完全不勉强你
你告诉他什么理由不演就可以了
所以我在那边很很舒服
我觉得人生可以不止一个故乡
有一个来处
但是你在不同的地方都有家庭归属感
在香港的时候
在1986年啊
青霞姐刀马旦头发剪得很短
因为那时候引起了一个风潮
很多人都剪了一个很短的头发
1988年
今夜星光灿烂
那么甚至呢后来就跨足到武侠世界
有1992年笑傲江湖之东方不败
同年呢还有新龙门客栈
颠倒众生
另外大家永远忘不了的是王家卫导演
1994年的重庆森林
还有1994年
东邪西毒大放异彩
香港导演创造了新的青霞姐
而您也成为他们的缪斯
让他们创造出以前没有拍过的类型剧
您在既得到香港适应上面
不管心境或者是剧情角色上
那时候有没有最艰难的挑战
我最伤心的是一个导演说了一句话
他在拍君子好逑
林岭东
我怎么演都不对
然后她说我说我哪里不对
他说你这个很有台湾味
那我在想这我有点难过台湾味
后来我想他这样子讲
可能是我的节奏太慢
因为香港说话的节奏很快
所以我就自己必须要调试自己
那就是这一点点困难了
其他没什么可以印象很深
这对我印象很深
心情好调试吗
在香港收购了以后
回去就一个人了
在那那段拍戏的日子里
面对非常寂寞
基本上我都是片场酒店
片场酒店
那我就是有时候睡醒
感觉像我好像在一个荒岛
就是就我一个人
因为我家里人都没有到香港
而且10年都是我一个人在香港这么长的时间
有时候我回去哇
回去看着那个窗外的风景这么美
我看这个风景我竟然嚎啕大哭
我突然感觉这么美的风景
怎么只有我一个人看
我就打电话给张淑萍
我张祖平说你哭了
我说嗯
那我说我好寂寞
他说那你打电话给朋友啊
我说我这不是打了吗
很好笑
不是作家
不认识作家
哎呀金雅姐跟很多导演
很多很多法语片的导演
从窗外是宋纯寿导演
对不对
是我看青霞姐
第一部片子是枫叶情
我还记得是白景瑞导演
在台湾合作很多导演到香港有谭家明导演啊
当然啊徐克导演
王家卫导演
后来呃滚滚红尘的严浩导演哦
我这边只举出了非常少的一部分
这么多合作的导演啊
他们转移给您的电影人的典范是什么
他们带给你的影响是什么
呃记得1980年
我那个时候因为很多新闻
然后我就到美国去了
到美国去
谭家明是为了我到美国去拍的那部电影叫暗杀
暗杀
那她跟我说了一句话
我直到现在还记得
而且我直到现在才做得到
他跟我说
如果你不在乎别人的看法
你就成功了
我知道他那句话是对的
但是我做不到
但现在我快乐
因为我做到了又会写文章了
是不是我觉得我在听听小姐姐讲话的时候
我每次都没有防备
突然呢就峰回路转了
东方不败
拍摄过程
青霞姐姐的时候会跟我说
聂华我跟你讲
我这真的讲了很多次了
所以静雅姐是一个喜欢更新的人
但是一定有幕后的小故事
就是有一次我要东方不败
刚出现在一个一棵大树上
我要站在上面
那就可以说是几层楼高了
就站在上面就不要下来了
有树上有一块板子
我就站在那
然后呢他要制造东方不败的那个威武啊
出来的话那个那个气势啊
他就放很多鸽子
很多鸽子这样在我这个前面冲到后面
嗨
我心里想这个一定要一次
OK啊
这鸽子会不会砸到我啊
然后然后我就我就说
不管怎么样
我一定要做好
我一定要不要害怕
真的一只鸽子啪撞到我的脸上
马上我脸很痛肿起来
但是我还是继续演
我这样继续演
他才不会来第二次
别的歌怎么回头说你撞到林青霞了
还不快起来
那么还有一次我不知道讲过没有嗯
就是我拍那个呃龙门客栈前一天晚上
那个武术指导就说明天要拍这个很多剑
要拍你个大特写
就是很多剑会会刺到
会向你这个方向来
但我就说哎呀
那眼睛不是会不会刺到眼睛
那个美术值得那个呃武术指导就说不会的
他说如果有东西过来
你眼睛一定会闭起来
那我就是好特写嘛
我就一次
OK所以我就瞪大眼睛
那个剑要在前面挥
那个那个剑一直过来
你要把它挥掉
把那个剑挥掉
然后我就瞪大眼睛
灰灰灰灰灰
眼睛也不必吧
一直打到我的眼睛上
这次受伤了
还好我眼睛闭起来了
你想了一只大棍子
打到眼珠上
怎么得了啊
我痛得在地上
弯在地上痛得不得了
谁来我就拨走
那么完了之后
他们就叫我到那个车上去休息一下
我就照照镜子
我黑眼珠有一条白线
我说我黑眼珠怎么有一条白线
他们说可能是羽毛啊
我是不知道可能是羽毛
我就滴眼药水的
滴滴滴
怎么滴
那条黑白线还在
我哭了一晚上
后来第二天去看眼科
眼科说你这个要是不来看
你眼睛就瞎了
他说你内眼膜裂开了
那条白线
就眼膜裂开了
我当晚就收拾行李啊
就就回香港哇
就东皇这样一路赶回香港
因为你要就医啦
我就说我在我戴一个帽子
怕人家认得我戴一个眼罩
你看我那个造型
戴个帽子
戴个眼罩
然后自己一个人孤身上了飞机
那个那个就趴在那个前面那个桌子那边这样子
一路上耸着肩膀这么哭
空中小姐不知道觉得我怎么样
我一直这样子
一路哭到香港
不过我一直打电话给我妈
说没事
因为大家都说我眼睛出事了
我觉得差不多了吧
就是到那个时候
是不是那个前后后来真的决定吸引了我
眼睛出了很多状况
我讲太多
你是不是不会不会
你可以把你所有的状况我们单独剪一集
叫东方不败的状况
你是不是差不多也就是那几年你真的想吸引
差不多那几年我真的想吸
因为身心互相影响嘛
你那么差不多就多意外哦
就是就是那个那个到第2年吧
那个那个戏大概九二我94年吸引的嘛
你有好多啊
讲习影好像不太对诶
我从来没说我不拍戏啊
对对对
修正修正修正我从来不这段不要剪掉
这段是我要confess认错
修正
没有吸引到金马奖
这个领终身成就奖都没有讲吸引
我一直说走入家庭
走入家庭
走入嫁为人妇
走入家庭这八个字也差不多
在那个时候对对啊
走入家庭
我们觉得林青霞又是经过一个
他比台湾搬到香港
有没有适应的地方
没有适应
真的我觉得我很是找到了一个港口
找到一个港口过渡得非常的自然
而且我也没停过没闲过
我结婚这么多
还是这么多记者拍
生了小孩又一直一直在忙
没停过
我一点都没有想过拍电影的事
但是呢我并没有忘了拍电影
嗯我我还是很爱表演
很爱电影的
所以他这是一个上天给青霞姐
我觉得一个很温厚的恩赐
青霞姐这一次呢带来了我觉得是送看板观众
全球华人观众的礼物哇
这个是2023年的呃
去呃不是哦
是今年啊
对对2023对对对
在巴黎
为什么这个对你很特别
我上次在看板人物
不是说我有个小小的愿望吗
我的愿望就是想摆摊画人像
而且希望是在巴黎的白教堂前面画
那我们那天就去了浩浩荡荡的
然后我们到那个巷子里
我就看到很多那个画画画的呢
艺术家就拿着一块大板子
然后就帮人家画
我我刚走近他就自己就画了
我也没有征求我同意就画了
就这样子啊
那我朋友也在旁边画
我就让他画
那画完了说我两个人200块欧元
哟真贵呀
200块欧元
那我就是好
我也想画人家
我说那我画你好了
我就帮他
我就画画画
就是这张
然后我画完了给他
我就送给你签名
送给他
旁边那个画家就很好奇
就过来看
他说这画家应该给你钱了啊
这个那你比较一下
我好来比较一下
你看他画
我跟我画
他我很好奇
后来你又帮他画
你又签了林青霞
虽然他应该是看不懂这签名的价值那200欧元
他还是给你收了
当然收了他他也没问
我也没告诉我多少钱
自己跑来画
那算了好
下次可否来台湾
我们这个TVB瑞光路人来人往
我大姐帮你准备一个帆布棚
包括先生跟三个女儿
她们必须要让你拥有你自己的时间空间
他们也不会怪我不理他们
我有时间就就大家一起吃晚饭呢
这个时间就真的是蛮少的了
先生很伟大
是伟大的
我是非常尊敬
说到青霞姐的话哈
这一次呢跟元月份非常不一样
青霞姐呢先传给我们看
他零的话
这个是常玉
常玉对他是吕发的画家
青霞姐
她很细心啊
她写给我训的时候
还说念华这话记得要横着哈哈哈哈哈
这是你的我的你开始零化
然后呢还有马蒂斯蒂斯
这个是我们在啊金马60
我们看到引言介绍青霞姐的这个片子里面
香港还在画的就是这一幅
这一幅好
可以讲一下呃
绿色条纹的马蒂斯夫人好好
另外呢呃是亨利马蒂斯他的画作
这一个零画带给你的乐趣是什么
这幅画是我在日本参观那个马蒂斯的画作
展览的
有一幅这幅画我最喜欢的就是这幅
就是感动
我画这幅画出来之后
我阿姨跟所有朋友都说画得像我好啊
你看看他说话的像我
你不觉得你眼睛里面那个感觉这个神情
这个味道我是特别要有一点点
这个这个不是跟她很像的
但是我觉得她整个那个人的那个气韵神情
我很喜欢
所以那第二张
因为这张照片这张画引起很大的人很大的批评
怎么说呢
就是他第一次画这个画是这样子的
没有人这样子画画画一条绿线
然后两边的脸不一样
遭了很大的恶评
然后他因为这个话得了忧郁症
他最最重要的画商把他定他的话给退掉了
就是因为这就因为这幅画
但是这幅画这幅画很宝贵
现在在后来在博物馆把它埋了
可见任何在艺术上面啊
大胆创新
常常有时候牺牲的是自己短暂的人生
那这个就更不得了了
常玉的这一幅真迹在香港拍卖的是吧
3亿哇
那林青霞林这个价值3亿的话呢
这个价值呢就不可不可测了
无价的啊
那没有我这个
那这就是没有没有钱
没必要钱是不需要钱
九岁以后是不是那时候圆月
我们聊天的时候
青霞解说
青霞姐给我们看素描
很多素描
现在就是我开始用画布画
开始用画布画
我嗯对我我准备
我希望我下一本书是可以用我的话
跟我的文章来做成出版
做成一本书出版
所以我们在借用艾琳的话
就静霞姐二女儿邢爱玲
在这次写我的妈妈林青霞啊
金马60的专刊里面
他还有一句话
她说我的妈妈呢就生活安排的很充实
他做的全部是她热爱的事
喜欢的事
有兴趣的事
所以我就很感谢我的先生跟我三个宝贝女儿
他们真的是很支持我做我有兴趣的事
毫无这真的是万分的支持
这个是我觉得非常感恩
非常珍惜的
所以包括先生跟三个女儿
这个时候那个世界里面
他们后面还会欣赏你的作品
可在那个的时候
他们必须要让你拥有你自己的时间空间
他们也不会怪我不理他们啊
啊我也没有特别不理我
有时间就就大家一起吃晚饭呢
差不多天天跟他们吃晚饭了
这个时间就真的是蛮少的了
她的先生很伟大
是伟大的
我是非常尊敬他
我非常尊敬他
你能尊敬一个先生
这是很难得的
是很少听到
真的很少听到女性朋友或是女性公众人物
用尊敬这个字来形容对啊
先生的感受绝对尊敬绝对尊敬
还有很多在啊
2023年清华姐从事里很有意义的
因为我我想我们都没有听过
这也是为什么青霞姐说八岁的这个原因
青霞姐在香港好
她现在跟致力于一个高空慈善基金会
跟香港中文大学一起赞助的脑至同户的项目
是大使脑是我们人脑智是智力
脑智同户
现在其实呃6789十岁都可以从事一个新的
启发自己新的潜能
但是就是说我们要呼吁大家要注意这个呃
脑子这个退化的这个这件事情
因为有的人忽略了
有的人那个脑退化是隐形的
你不知道你不知道
你就不知道怎么去防范
那么有的是有轻微的
然后刚好有机缘就认识了高空的太太啊
这个香港的一个医生的赵夏莹医生
那么大家还有一个中文大学脑做
对于这方面是专家的那个莫少堂院长
我们一拍即合
做了这个这个公益活动
那我觉得是非常有意义的
我觉得是现今社会社会最需要的
昨天我救了我自己几趟
我一下车呢
我穿了个高跟鞋
大概五六寸吧
地上都是石头
我扭了一下
赶快扭回来
但我要那个拐很漂亮
就啪就把那个衣服这样举起来
到后面就拍了
很东方不败啊
金小姐
在这个脑致同户的这样一个有意义的唤起上
不只是大使
你参与的跟投入的很多补救防患最好
重要的最好的就是有一个很愉快的社交活动啊
让你保持你的这个心情愉快啊
多打一点乒乓球
做一点运动
打乒乓球上次没有提到乒乓球
我天天打
天天打
所以运动对于自己的不管体力心境
还有你的记性
清雅姐跟我说
你的记性绝对比60岁以前好
我的记性比以前是好很多
是真的好很多
所以脑子反应也好
不然我怎么顶得住你啊
谢谢东方不败的赞美哦
好我们刚刚最后啊就提到了啊
很快很快青霞姐呃
刚刚提到愉快的社交
其实是啊对于我们的身心里有很大的注意
在这一次大家终于看到了
在这个影言影片里面
我们听到了青霞姐呢唱了京戏
那金霞姐也跟葛兰姐啊一起一起票京戏
同时我在啊金马转播里面看到江青小姐
她全程坐在台下
一定是你很好的朋友
很好的朋友的典礼
她专程从瑞典赶过来参加我的这个活动
这个支持我看过青霞姐写这一些
大概世代上跟她在前一个时代的女性
让你最喜欢跟他们在一起的时候
你最喜欢的部分是什么
我跟你讲
我真的很尊敬很尊敬呃
喜爱欣赏江青
他是这样的刻苦要追求自己创作的人
我真的没有办法想象一个电影明星啊
以前是个电影明星
他竟然一辈子没有擦过指甲油
没有染过头发
有一次金马奖邀请他过来颁奖
然后他是从最远的过来
他从瑞典过来
金马奖要付那个旅费的时候
就很奇怪
为什么你最远的你的你的机票最便宜
他说我坐经济舱咯
他说我都是坐经济舱的
我要把所有的钱都放在我的创作里面啊
他的脚为了为了跳舞啊
这个变形了
那你看他的脚
你不会觉得他丑
你会觉得哎呀
很心疼
这就是她的故事
她一辈子就是为舞蹈而活啊
我们昨天晚上跳舞
两个人跳得很开心
跳到三点多半夜
所以现在的体力绝对比以前好
所以又是一个临阵
还可以跟江青影后将倾尬舞尬舞啊
就好像有人要跟东方不败比武的
意思是一样的好
我想呃青霞姐带给我们的感动啊
带给我们的呃启发振奋嗯
我觉得是跨时代的
想问青霞姐哦
这个医生一直关关过最快乐的地方在哪
他们可能会记得好多辛苦的地方
快乐的地方
我跟你讲
你说记得好多辛苦的地方
有的辛苦的地方反而是快乐的地方
而且我觉得我现在任何事情
都是可以令到我快乐的啊
那个像以前会沮丧会
我都觉得我这人生需要幽默
像昨天的昨天我救了我自己几趟
昨天昨天我一下车呢
我穿了个高跟鞋
大概五六寸吧
红毯的时候红毯我一下车呢
就那个高跟鞋
就那个地上都是石头
我扭了一下
赶快扭回来
我我我就觉得我是最近我练脚力
是真的练的很好
这是pose会扭伤的
然后我那上那个红的红楼梯
那个不是拖拖拉拉拖地啊
高跟鞋这么高啊
又地毯啊什么
我走走走到拐了一下
但我要那个拐很漂亮
啪就把那个衣服这样举起来
到后面就拍了
很东方不败
但是在里面拐哦
昨天呢昨天呢我又有我自己都很佩服我自己
我说张叔平
她把我从一个乡下土包子变成窈窕淑女
我想窈窕淑女们窈窕一下了
我就把那个把那裙子一拉
噗噜噗噜
那个鞋鞋子很高嘛
不噜不噜又拐了一下诶
可是他说在台上哦
我是在台上啊
我就在台上哎呀
一说到窈窕
马上就不窈窕了
就弄回来
然后我朋友说都不觉得你叠
以为你是就是这样子故意的
那是在台上台上台上我我拐了一下嘛
我终于知道人家讲那个得意的笑是什么
就是就是这种笑
好得意好不好
这个后面最记得这个金马奖上台的
这个变成你非常记得
但我觉得真的很惊险
是惊险啦
很惊险啊
我这咕咕咕可能会摔的很难看啊
对不对
那个还没个桌子抓嘞
没桌子抓他一条很
今年跟往年不一样
他是一条细致
我还不知道要哈哈哈
要扶也没得扶
还好我又扭回来
最近练那个皮拉提斯那个腿劲啊
脚劲儿都练到了
金马筹备过程的时候公布了终身成就奖
是青霞姐的时候
那几句话真的让我觉得好像是嗯
怎么说呢
我觉得不管男性女性吧
我们都很希望能够仰望的那个典范
他是这么说的
他经历各种类型考验
屹立不摇的巨型魅力
犹如传奇
创造了传奇
青霞姐
您期待电影事业
它除了反映我们人性所有的喜怒哀乐之外
你其他电影事业能够在心灵层面带来哪些
更深入的影响和功能
我喜欢我喜欢看对你对人有启发的电影
有共鸣的
就说演员
你不管你认识不认识
我就喜欢看那种真的像你讲的喜怒哀乐
可以从发自内心的这个真的感受
不是说外表的那个眼
就像我喜欢看法国女作家安妮
就是去年得诺贝尔奖的那个作家
我喜欢他的文章
就是他所有的东西都是从里面最深沉最深刻
这创伤
这所有都是从里面这样子发出来
像是从灵魂写出来的
都是真的
我喜欢看这种啊
我觉得这种能够反映就反映一些呃
这个人性的真谛的这种东西啊
我们一起期待啊
青霞姐她的第五本书
后面还有好多本书
还有青霞姐的话
就像你讲的
在终身成就奖里面还您创造了跨时代的巨星
魅力
犹如传奇
我们也希望你反映更多
我们人性里面我们说不出的
我们感受的
今天我要最后就问这么一个问题
没有吸引这件事
没有吸引
就是主持人说错了
没有吸引这件事
对不对
很多导演在找我哈哈
敬请期待
我们现在有一天我的第三次机会访问青霞姐
谢谢青霞姐不一定拍啊
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢
谢雅婷是谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢